you should give Josh points for not
adding a testicle in his icecream
I can break something fresh on top yeah
maybe no testicle I'm not into that too
much
[Music]
guys it's Mike Chen welcome to Coneheads
on first we feast
now summers here the temperature's
rising and in the food world that really
just means one thing ice cream so every
single week I'm gonna be exploiting some
of the most delicious frozen meats in
the world all from the comforts of my
own home and I'm taking you with me and
I know during lockdown a lot of us are
cooking polishing our culinary skills
watching tutorials online let that all
melt away from your brain because here
on Kong hands we've got the latest scoop
on some amazing ice cream hacks that are
just legend wait for it dary
legendary virtual high five and to kick
things off I got one of my favorite
YouTube chefs joining me Josh sure he's
gonna show us simple ice cream DIY
recipes that you can make at home that
will for sure level up a Super Saiyan
eyes your ice cream game and you might
have seen Josh on good mythical morning
he's also has his own channel mythical
kitchen where he's teaching everyone how
to cook everything from a $300
in-and-out burger to testicles so Josh
thanks for joining us
yeah Mike thank you so much for plugging
my bull testicles that we actually have
testicles available at the mythical
story that's mythical dot store for all
your bull testicle needs very good
information to know I thought I wouldn't
bring up testicles in the first two
minutes of this episode and it already
happened I'm sorry guys all right Josh
now back to ice cream um I got a
question for you why do you like making
ice cream at home instead of going to a
store yeah I think homemade ice cream is
really fun right it's like infinitely
customizable when you make it at home
and I think things always taste better
when your hands up like physically touch
them you know it means a lot more to you
to be able to like you know eat a
product that you've created rather than
something that's just store-bought so
like it's fun and also you know like you
said turning lock down people are boning
up on their cooking skills might as well
include ice cream into that cannon you
own Sam where do we start
hi man so we are going to start with the
recipe that I believe Martha Stewart is
actually sort of responsible for
creating now with what we know about her
and Snoop Dogg she may have been stoned
when she did it more power to her so
we're going to start with a method
that's super easy all you have to do is
basically whipped cream fold in your
sweeteners and then all it does is sit
in the freezer so like no churning no
ice cream makers no nothing just you and
the power of Martha Stewart Stone
forearms
legally I can't say she was stoned due
to libel reasons alright Josh you
convinced me let's make some ice cream
let's do it brother let's get the cream
in that cream hi Josh I got all the
ingredients you told me to get how do we
transform this into something I can
stuff in my mouth all right man so this
is what I'm calling like the hacked up
version of homemade ice cream right so
all you're gonna do is gonna take the
heavy whipping cream and you're gonna
whip it by hand so you wanna pour your
own physical blood sweat and tears into
this that's actually what seasons it and
then you're gonna pour in the sweetened
condensed milk a little bit vanilla
extract and then when you set this in
the freezer overnight all the air
bubbles from the whipping are actually
gonna set it to this like beautiful ice
creamy consistency so you're looking for
soft peaks
you don't want stiff peaks and you don't
want Twin Peaks I've never seen it I've
heard it's really great so you want soft
peaks which means that if you put a
spoon in it it should be able to kind of
peak up by itself and then slowly
drizzle down ain't nothin to it but to
do it man just shove your whisk in the
bowl and start creaming that cream all
right I got you I'm just gonna go and
you want to spray cream inches all over
your cooking station you're gonna keep
your muscles loose don't tense up see do
it you really seriously workout video
kitchen utensils you like the white lady
Brentwood workout class come on give us
buck pickers you on athlete's feet
season coming up dude respondent
negative or positive reinforcement you
like tense the shoulder and get the hips
into it cool Mike you can do this pick
up the pace way am i kicking you're
peaking man Mike you got the softest
peaks in the game I think we're ready to
fold in the condensed milk in the
vanilla all right perfect so when you're
saying folding in what do you mean by
that for people who don't speak shut all
right so what you're doing is you're
basically trying to not deflate the
cream because when ice cream is made in
the factory it has what's called overrun
which is the amount of air that's been
pumped into it and when you turn it
that's what's happening so right now
you've basically like pre turn to air in
your ice cream so you don't want to
deflate it you basically want to start
at the sides of the bowl and then just
gently bring it towards the middle
you're gonna take that and all you're
gonna do is dump it into whatever
container you have I'm just using a
solid I'm gonna make up a measurement a
13 centimeter by two and a half
centimeter loaf pan let it set in that
loaf pan pop it in the freezer let it
sit overnight you and I are gonna have a
virtual sleepover where I don't know we
just watched all the Marvel movies
that's how real girls Hank
[Music]
hi Mike this has been setting overnight
how'd you sleep
been thinking about this all night I had
night terrors how you have ice cream
waiting for you it's like something
beautiful waiting for you in the morning
I slept so sweetly
that's a beautiful perspective I think I
should probably just talk to someone
okay so let's take into this let's see
how the ice cream actually turned out it
scoops like real ice cream it is real
ice cream what am I saying this is ice
cream making ice cream at home is easy
and you should do it oh yeah this is a
workout too is it supposed to be this is
it man this is your recovery workout you
get rewarded with the ice cream after
your workout that's how it works
cheers buddy and where's the old country
look I'm you know actually tastes like
ice cream I don't know why I was
doubting it the whole time I've done
this before but every time I'm just like
this isn't gonna taste like ice cream it
does you know you're not gonna make the
best ice cream that you've ever had at
home you know there's people who devoted
their entire lives to that Mike you've
devoted approximately nine minutes to
making ice cream but this is still
pretty solid right it's solid ice cream
it's definitely sweet oh yeah hmm
another chef's trick if you're ever
worried about your technique dump a
bunch of sugar into the food it tastes
better I know you're really good a lot
of things but what I'm good at
it's tossing a bunch of crap into a bowl
and make it taste good so I challenge
you man I'm throwing down ice cream
sundae battle it's a crap off
[Music]
all right the moment we've been all
waiting for all my Sunday ingredients
are laid out Josh I see you got all
yours there as well
let the Sunday death match begin you go
first buddy la cuisine all right so I
was a lot of Iron Chef America I'm gonna
little bit simple with this I'm doing
kind of like a taken like a fried banana
split so I'm gonna take my nanners I'm
gonna cut them little off shapes I'm
gonna toss them in the hot oil I have no
idea how hot this oil is it might just
explode in my face and then if I die
Mike wins by default I guess there we go
those are frying up nice so we got the
nanners frying I really like kind of
burnt in caramely flavors so I'm gonna
melt some butter in a pan and toss in a
bunch of brown sugar and I'm gonna drink
the shot of bourbon olives out of the
Bourbon in there are you gonna make it
flame up as well you gonna add that to
your arsenal oh my good should we do
that Trevor grab me a blowtorch
now we are I've got my live-fire
privileges revoked in this kitchen that
is a real thing we've had to have some
talks about it all right we got this
caramel sauce working oh that's lovely
Oh No spill sugar I got the ice cream
I'm just gonna layer my fried bananas
around it make it look nice and pretty
now I'm gonna take that brown sugar
bourbon caramel and I'm just gonna get
that all over the bananas in the ice
cream I'm licking up my breakfast Sunday
man I wouldn't be surprised if he
doesn't have a cherry in his back pocket
to put on top of that Trevor actually
legit find the looks are no cherries in
the fridge and throw them at me those
seems like a cyst I got an assistant
look man I'm bringing back up to a fight
you're calling this a death match I'm
gonna have Trevor throwing cherries to
me throw in some salted peanuts on there
for a little crunch
we got the fancy looks our dough
cherries this isn't your maraschino this
is the stuff they put in like a
Manhattan cocktail we're dropping that
on there too I'm calling it a day
I'm calling this down expelled a little
bit of burnt sugar we got the Luxardo
cherry
bourbon caramel fried banana split a
little bit of salted peanuts on top Mike
your move buddy I don't have any fire in
mind but I did bring the hates because
mine's gonna be a simple recipe I got my
trusty cleaver I got some KitKat's I got
some Pocky or imitation Pocky and some
little marshmallows so Kit Kat smash it
with my cleaver that's a pro move Mike
you are
chef man never sell yourself short again
I got my personal hot oil that I made I
always keep it back to this on hand this
is a little sesame oil sesame seed
vegetable oil fried chilies and bits of
sesame in there as well so you get a
little crunch you get a little saltiness
you're definitely getting a lot of
spiciness put our Pocky sticks in there
a little bit of marshmallows go in
that's looking pretty man you got the
crown of Pocky in there in another
trizol there you go
you can also chopstick the thing that's
that is a beautiful thing like all right
Josh I gotta say your Sunday looks
pretty darn good
fancy schmancy mine looks like a hot
mess literally but we need an impartial
judge and I can't think of anyone better
all the way from France Alex from Alex
French guy cooking hey welcome to the
show Ali hey Mike how are you thank you
so much for this hey man I just want to
say thank you so much for being here
your your classes look amazing it's just
awesome stop booing me up
Alex whatever Mike's paying you I'll
double I don't care what it takes I need
to win this thing I got kids man I don't
have any kids I lied I'm sorry it
doesn't work for me so sorry guys it
doesn't work on me I'm just gonna be the
most impartial judge ever I've got two
amazing ice cream in front of me and I'm
dying to try them out so what we did
here was that we sent Alex our
ingredients list in cooking instruction
and heat of course it is all
interpretation on our recipes this
Robert Josh's Josh won't tell Alex would
you would you cooked yes Alex what you
have prepared for you today is a fried
banana split we have some beautifully
caramelized banana should have a little
bit of complexity and that nice brulee
flavor we have some salted peanuts and
then a bourbon brown sugar caramel
please chef enjoy what you have created
for you okay I'm going I'm going in I'm
going for a good scoop of both the sauce
the banana the ice cream
that's very good not gonna night that's
very good see holding this year if you
don't you don't get 3.4 speaking French
month my man Justin Perth so we're just
amazing the sweetness is not
overpowering that's what I would say cuz
I think the bananas and the caramelized
vibe is springy also a bit of toasty I
don't know something shower toasty
something that that past quite went with
the bobbin the Bowman has that smoky
flavor as well so it's like a grown-up
ice cream somehow in terms of like wow
factor yeah it's a bit it might be just
to touch expected chef I tried to show
restraint I know you're a classy guy
I'm a classy guy I'm gonna show you my
technique yeah exactly
you're right this is classic can I go on
to the next one Mike first of all the
other one is just cleaner visually it's
very easy to distinct the different
elements it looks a bit childish to be
honest that's me my inner icecream child
is screaming out exactly there's nothing
wrong with a childish ice-cream
especially a sundae I'm all for this
like bombs on movie nights I would make
myself something that is similar to this
- and that's that's the thing that just
keeps on you know poking my brain mine
is the chili oil
are you mad are you mad then it's just
this might be like just a boat or a
stupid bull I don't know this is it this
is a good fight Mike this is real
I mean GTI is not bad to be honest
Chilean it hasn't some you know what I'm
starting to feel something similar to
this one oh I'm getting the kick OH
oh my skates this is pure endorphin I
guess so I'm getting something similar
to your dish at first I thought these
ice creams now just diametrically
opposed
but then the Chia brings it back to this
there's some similarities in your two
dishes
alright the suspense is killing me I see
that me and Josh have both taken up the
waiting for the verdict polls which is
like hands behind the back
anxiously awaiting your judgement yes
chef if you had to pick one Alex which
one would you pick by the way nice
glasses it's not working so we
compliment come up with something
greater than this if I want to be in a
restaurant and I see both of these on
the menu
vanilla ice cream chili oil and boom
boom banana vanilla ice cream it's gonna
sound weird I think I would out taste
the chili oh oh
some day is my favorite day and that is
why he's not even a real chef you just
needs food on the Internet the reason is
simple I
I love stepping out of my comfort zone
III II I live and breathe for the
creative side of cooking and that just
speaks to something weird inside my mind
that's me if this one is good it's good
this one just it's fun it's funny I like
what's funny
[Music]
it's been a pleasure spinning the
morning with you making these great
creations Josh thank you so much for
Delta DIY ice cream hacks also really
awesome didn't know I could actually
make ice cream this easily in my own
kitchen Alex thank you so much for
coming on the show
you've been the ultimate judge I highly
respect your opinion and guys definitely
check out their channels
Mikko kitchen is amazing and Alice
French guy cooking to your amazing chef
amazing Channel check that out as well
one last fight for a great setup guys
cheers everyone
cheers Cheers
I think mine's a winner
[Music]
[Applause]
you